bienvenue dans PAF avec Stéphane Monson
bonjour Doyer honoraire de la Faculté de
droit on dit ça comme ça on dit ça comme
ça et c'est à vie hon c'estou mais vous
étiez vous TZ un très jeune doyen donc
et honoraire c'est pire et honoraire
c'est pire et toujours professeur de
droit public donc à l'université de
Versailles centin on ne m'a toujours pas
viré voilà mais il y a aucune raison je
pense et on reste dans les juristes avec
Florence percadé qui est toujours
avocate au barreau de versaill
absolument bonjour Patrice Jean-Luc madc
bonjour Des Templiers alors vous allez
être heureux parce que en face de vous
il y a quelqu'un qui a essayé de
renverser la table de la vie politique
je crois enfin on and c'est Thomas
courtois il essaye mais il on va l'aider
on va l'aider oui je ne suis pas tout
seul il faut être plusur voilà vous êtes
l'objectif il faut être plusieurs
absolument vous vous êtes un des membres
un deses fondateurs mais enfin vous êtes
depuis le début de de nous citoyens vous
en êtes le le délégué pour
l'Île-de-France ouest parce qu'il y a
des découpages un peu particuliers pour
enfin pour vous et vous nous expliquerez
voilà on va parler de ce ce nveau
mouvement est-ce que c'est un parti
est-ce que c'est autre chose quelles
sont vos ambitions quels sont vos buts
pourquoi ça a été créé est-ce que vous
êtes content des résultats que vous avez
acquis jusqu'ici vous allez nous en
parler à côté de vous Sephora Namani ça
va bien Patrice oui merci très bien
toujours à l'université aussi mais vous
étudiez oui toujours a qui enseignne il
y en a qui étudient voilà et
Jean-Charles lajoignie éditeurour
toujours et toujours aux éditions La
jooignie donc absolument mieux qu'on
ça'pporte votre nom voilà c'est plus
simple alors on parlera on va parler de
NS citoyens on parlera d'autres sujets
on va parler notamment du décret
d'application sur la sur la réforme de
l'enseignement on parlera peut-être de
de cette décision sur la de la Cour de
cassation sur la GPA c'est un avis pour
l'instant c'est un avis de l'avocat
général de la Cour de cassation et ce
sera étudié je crois fin mai devant la
cour de cassasionà qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que deviennent les les enfants
qui sont nés de la GPA dans un pays
étranger les enfants français on regarde
l'inscription à l'état civil absolument
et mais d'abord on va commencer par par
vous et puis par par la politique alors
un mot d'abord nous citoyens c'était une
réponse à moi Président c'est ça
exactement c'est une réponse aux
anaphores le moi président avec les les
10 anaphores je crois la la réponse est
nous citoyens donc c'est un la la
vocation ou l'ambition de de nous
citoyens c'est de regrouper des hommes
et des femmes de conviction qui on envie
de comme vous disiez tout à l'heure de
renverser la table h et je vous êtes
dedans ou quoi écoutez j'ai participé
aux deux premières réunions organisées
par Denis perère à Paris un personnage
pre il faut dire un mot c'est le
fondateur hein de le fondateur de nos
citoyens citoyens euh brillant
intellectuellement euh très belle
réussite dans les affaires et qui a
voulu finalement créer un un mouvement
que j'ai trouvé intéressant parce que
allant dans des démarches novatrice
cassant des codes et il avait pour
ambition et j'ai trouvé ça très
intéressant de créer ce qu'il appelait
un mouvement
transpolitique hélas piégé par les
médias et par les autres
partis du un petit parti politique
dommage
critique qu'on peut qu'on peut mettre
mais d'abord savoir ce que c'est que ce
ce ce mouvement vous êtes à droite à
gauche au centre ou ailleurs ça à
l'extrême centre nous sommes un
mouvement extrême donc donc non partisan
puisque nous regroupons et et les les
adhérents sont des gens qui viennent
soit de gauche soit de droite et une des
grandes idées de de Niper c'est qu'il y
a des bonnes idées à gauche il y a des
bonnes idées à droite et que un peu de
pragmatisme en politique ne ferine mal à
personne vousê vous êtes un chef
d'entreprise oui entreprise famille mais
importante de plus de 300 salariés je
crois deny per vient aussi de
l'entreprise tout à fait c'est un donc
est-ce que c'est pas une une sorte de
façon voilà pour les chefs d'entreprise
de se dire au fond le pays est mal géré
si on le gérait comme une entreprise ça
irait beaucoup mieux euh sur certains
principes oui c'est c'est ce que je
disais auparavant c'est d'amener du
pragmatisme en politique donc il est
vrai que le le le le mouvement a démarré
surtout avec des chefs d'entreprise du
fait du par cours de de de Perre mais on
s'aperçoit aujourd'hui un an et demi
après que on regroupe des avocats des
juristes des artisans des commerçants
des cadres et et petit à petit la base
la base s'élargie à force d'aller au
contact des Français de leur expliquer
qui on est d'où on vient moi je me suis
engagé il y a 1 an et demi en politique
c'estit mon coming out politique et au
aujour prier premier engagement
politique tout à fait de militant oui
donc je suis à la fois adhérant militant
et maintenant délégué régional parce que
j'ai fais partie peut-être des premiers
à à entendre Denis Perre un matin sur
BFM en disant est-ce que je reste dans
le camp des râurs ou est-ce que je passe
enfin dans le camp des acteurs pour
sortir de la majorité silencieuse vous
êtes des déçus de la politique au pour
dire ça déçus de la politique partie des
85 % de Français qui n'ont plus
confiance dans les partis traditionneles
chez nous on les appelle les vieux
partis h alors bon je posais assez de
questions je vous laisse parler avec
avec Thas courtois et alors vous avez
combien de d'adhérents ant à NS citoyens
aujourd'hui nous sommes nous avons 13000
adhérents et plus particulièrement sur
le l'Île-de-France ouest 800 adhérents
sur les c'est vous qui avez le plus de
grand nombre oui oui on gagne on est
devant les autres régions donc prendre
le pouvoir ou comme on n absolument pas
dans cette logique
là je vous dis aujourd'hui je ne suis
candidat absolument à rien si ce n'est à
faire avancer le mouvement et donner un
peu de montant pour eu des candidatures
quand même aux élections mais
heureusement la vocation d'un d'un
mouvement politique que nous sommes un
parti c'est-à-dire que il y a des
statutes qui ont été déposés c'est un
parti pour pouvoir collecter des fonds
collecter des adhésions et pour pouvoir
présenter des candidats et justement
pour nous différencier d'un tin tank qui
réfléchit beaucoup qui aide justement
parce qu'on est entouré aujourd'hui de
Ting tank ou de d'organismes qui
réfléchissent avec nous et qui nous
aident tels que l'ifrapp et d'autres euh
l'app c'est quoi l'rapp c'est l'Institut
des euh c'estit un mouvement avec euh
excusez-moi j'ai un trou euh de avec euh
Valérie c'est un institut de de Ré oui
qui réfléchit qui qui qui est capable
aujourd'hui d'analyser les les
compre-rendus de la Cour des comptes et
qui après nous aide à à à trouver des
solutions comment passer de d'un
endettement tel qu'on le connaît de 57 %
du PIB à 40 % voilà parce qu'il y a des
sources de de et des gisements
d'économie qui sont considérables donc
on est entouré et on fére un certain
nombre de deting tank et pour pouvoir
justement renverser la table comme vous
le disiez tout à l'heure il faut bien à
un moment un autre euh pas prendre le
pouvoir mais avoir des élus pour pouvoir
porter notre parole au plus haut des des
décisions résat c'est pas fabuleux quand
même aux élections euh c'est vous qui le
dites non non je je j'ai l'impression
sans être dans sans tomber dans la
langue de bois je vais vous donner des
des choses très très factuelles déjà
13000 adhérences ça nous positionne où
sur sur les chiquier je crois que c'est
le terme consacré
euh pour peu que les autres partis
donneent les vrais chiffres d'après nos
estimations nous sommes 10e force
politique en France si on se base sur
les élections européennes de mai de
l'année dernière mai 2014 le les
résultats obtenus nous positionnent et
confirme ce positionnement ce résultat
de 10e force politique en France lors
des élections départementales euh qui
ont eu lieu il y a il y a pas très
longtemps nous avions fait le choix de
ne pas avoir des candidats partout mais
au contraire d'avoir quelques candidats
identifiés qui ont signé la charte
citoyenne qui se sont engagé sur le
cumul des mandats et sur le non cumul
des mandats justement euh avec des
engagements forts eu nous avons réussi
avec une vingtaine de binômes sur ces
régionsl sur ces départements là à
obtenir en moyenne 8 % des voix 8 %
c'est pas négligeable exactement et au
deuxème tour avec les candidats qui
étaient présents nous avons obtenu
autant de voix en France que Europe
Écologie les vers h Stéphane Monon c'est
c'est pas la première fois qu'il y a des
des des des nouveaux partis ou des
nouveaux mouvements qui arrivent est-ce
qu'ils ont du du mal à se frayer un
chemin dans la dans la vie politique
traditionnel alors heureusement que
c'est pas la première fois dans un pays
démocratique même si la France et et en
vous entendant vraiment moi je je je je
j'avais comment dirais-je des
réminiscences
historiques et la question est-ce que
c'est nouveaux partis ont du mal à se
frayer un chemin parmi les partis
traditionnels euh oui euh oui surtout en
France parce que la France a toujours
s'est toujours méfié d'ailleurs on
l'entend un peu dans votre discours
c'est toujours méfié terriblement des
partis politiques là où en
Grande-Bretagne par exemple enfin au
Royaume-Uni les partis politiques sont
installés dès la fin du 17e siècle Enfin
très tôt très très tôt il a une très
forte tradition démocratique et
parlementaire qu'on ne retrouve pas en
France le le le premier gros parti
politique français il existe d'ailleurs
toujours aujourd'hui vous le savez c'est
le parti radical créé en 1901 avant
faute de partis politique on avait
affaire à une démocratie balbuciante
essentiellement accès auour de la
notabilité c'està-dire que c'était le
notable du coin qui avait des moyens
suffisants pour animer autour de lui une
espèce de coterie et qui se faisait
élire au aux diverses élections la
France se méfie des partis on parlait au
19e siècle de l'impensable notion parce
que c'est une espèce de division de
l'Intérieur là où l'idéal
révolutionnaire en 1789 posait
précisément l'idéal contraire
c'est-à-dire une nation composée
d'individus sans et je vais utiliser un
terme ch à Jean-Luc sans corps
intermédiaires susceptible de faire
écran entre le citoyen et l'ensemble
national il avit les corporatismes qu'il
fallait balayer ont été balayés en 1791
par la loi Le Chapelier alors toutes les
associations professionnelles les
universités qui étaient des corporations
ont été supprimé et cetera et donc pas
de parti politique c'est pour ça que à
cette époque-là on voit fleurir les les
clubs he plus connu étant le club des
Jacobins et cetera alors qui était au
fond des partis qui ne disaient pas leur
nom mais il il y a un paradoxe quand
même je je vous écoutais alors vous
dites d'un côté on est un parti et
cetera et moi enfin je suis d'accord
pour moi le terme
parti ne me choque pas enfin
le le parti politique est une une
organisation une machine qui qui
concours dit la Constitution à
l'expression du suffrage et qui qui est
une aide une aide indispensable au bon
fonctionnement d'une bonne santé
démocratique d'un pays mais d'un autre
côté enfin peut-être il s'agissait de
vous à titre personnel mais vous dites
ben on veut pas prendre le pouvoir mais
le but d'un parti c'est et il y a pas de
honte c'est de se saisir
démocratiquement du de se faire conduire
au pouvoir pour justement changer les
choses tout à fait c'est parce qu'il y a
une telle défiance aujourd'hui vis-àvis
des partis politiques que déjà on c'est
pour ça je pense que vous aviez posé la
question on se présente plus en tant que
mouvement dans le mouvement Al après
c'est est-ce que c'est de la sémantique
ouut mais quand vous allez
surou moi qui fait mon coming out
politique il y a pas très longtemps
quand vous allez sur les marchés quand
vous allez tracter quelque chose de
nouveau pour quand vous avez collé des
affiches euh il y a un travail militant
comme ça vous le faites enfin il faut
oui parce que c'est comme dans notre
entreprise pas enfin je ne suis pas un
patron qui reste dans un bureau et qui
travaille par mail à un moment autre il
faut aller avec les équipes sentir
est-ce que est-ce que les clients sont
satisfaits voilà c'est c'est c'est la
même chose quand il y a des éventuelles
parutions après il faut aller sur la sur
le terrain pour voir si nos idées
convain est-ce que on est dans le vrai
est-ce que est-ce que le message j'
entendu et donc voilà il notre mouvement
aujourd'hui il est fait aussi de de gens
petit à petit qui nous rejoignent pour
être élu pour être candidat nous avons
fait le mouvement la semaine dernière
n'a pas fait le pont certains faisaient
la grève d'autres faisaent le pont nous
on travaillait parce qu'on préparait le
séminaire des régionales pour pour pour
décembre et donc où il y aura des
candidats dans toutes les régions
l'ambition et d'avoir des candidats dans
toutes les régionsord dans les 13
régions euh c'est une grosse une grosse
machine à mettre en place parce que
quand on est un mouvement qui ne vit que
de ses que de ses adhésions pardon voilà
nous avons peu de moyens mais avec peu
de moyens comme on est en France on peut
avoir des idées et être innovant se
servir des réseaux sociaux et de et
d'autres d'autres Biss de communication
jeanchles c'est une je sais pas une
initiative qui vous parle trouve c'est
toujours sympathique d'avoir des des des
nouveaux partis des nouveaux mouvements
qui qui se créent euh après bon je
toujours un peu perplexe quand on dit on
est l'extrême centre en fait en gros
l'extrême centre suivant C position
personnelle ça veut dire so on est en
gros on est à droite ça très souvent
l'extrême l'extrême centre c'est souvent
une façon poli politiquement correct de
dire qu'on est plutôt à droite ENF en
tout cas qu'on est pas à gauche la
plupart du temps c'est ça c'est la
première chose c'est pas du tout une
tare pour moi bien au contraire mais
mais je trouve c'est aussi bien de le
dire et et puis l'autre chose c'est que
j'adore les chefs d'entreprise je c'est
passionnant et cetera mais la politique
c'est autre chose que que la gestion
d'une d'une entreprise quel que soit la
taille de l'entreprise c'est ça jamais
bien marché
parce que gérer gérer une entreprise
c'est merveilleux mais gérer la France
on gère pas une entreprise quand on gère
la France on a on a on a tous les
laissés pour compte on a tous les
problèmes sociaux on a les problèmes de
sécurité sociale on les problèmes de
vieux on a on a un nombre de de défense
nationale qui sont pas du tout du
ressort d'un chef d'entreprise donc je
comprends très bien qu'on puisse gérer
une une entreprise de façon merveilleuse
et extrêmement efficace est-ce que c'est
un modèle est-ce que c'est ça qui doit
faire rêver moi la politique je pense
que c'est autre chose et c'est un
engagement qui est au-delà de l'écon de
de de la pure vision économique si
la politique c'est pas que de l'économie
c'est vrai qu'on a eu des chefs
d'entreprise ministre de l'Économie des
Finances comme maire comme comme Breton
ça pas été les plus grand ministre de
l'Économie des Finances qu'on a jamais
eu hein oui par ont été ils ont été mis
du jour au lendemain dans un système
peut-être
technocratique on va peut-être pas se
aujourd'hui se plaindre d'avoir enfin
des chefs d'entreprise qui veulent
s'engager et et nous citoyens ce n'est
pas un mouvement de chef d'entreprise
vous AES vous avez des délégués
régionaux qui sont des journalistes
est-ce qu'on peut éventuellement parler
de l'engagement de journaliste en
politique voilà je vous pouvez
éventuellement Patrice nous nous
éclairer nous inspirer sur cette sur
cette quand quand il dit vous vous êtes
de droite vous répondez quoi moi je
viens plutôt de de de droite et le
candidat de nous citoyens rbouillé tu
quelqu'un de gauche et ben on arrive à
parler sans s'envoyer sans s'envoyer des
sauts d'insulte voilà je sais à partir
du moment vous avez des gens qui
sont animés par l'intérêt général qui
sont
qui essayent de qui mettent leurs
ambitions personnelles de côté vous
arrivez quand même à discuter à échanger
et avancer je vous donne juste un
exemple
sur la la charte citoyenne qui va être
éditée dans d'ici une quinzaine de jours
c'est un travail collectif assez assez
incroyable vous verrez que il y a de la
matière c'est pas juste un document que
le président a a écrit dans son bureau
ou a choisi deux personnes qui savaient
à peu près bien écrire pour sortir la
charte la charte elle était euh mené
pendant un bon mois par deux
vice-présidents é Éric de Lanois et
thbao Julie qui fait un travail
absolument remarquable qui ont pendu une
première une première ébauche du de la
Charte cette charte ensuite a été
proposée au Comité des régions dont je
fais partie il eu un véritable échange
où on ne cherchait pas le plus vecteur
commun le plus petit vecteur commun mais
plutôt à enrichir chacun avec nos
sensibilités la charte ensuite celle-ci
a été transmise à l'intégralité des
régions des délégués de région qui
avaient une quinzaine de jours pour
selon leur vouloir sans avoir un ordre
qui vient de Paris soit on l'a présenter
aux adhérents soit on l' présenter à nos
délégués dans les communes pour
l'enrichir et ce travail là nous de
collecte a été remonté sous une forme de
collaborative ou participative on parle
de plateforme collaborative au à au
vice-président pour avoir un document
enrichi de de l'intelligence de tout le
monde voilà les trois premières mesure
que vous prendriez c'est quoi si vous
étiez au pouvoir comme comme Stéphane
vous convi l'êre on commencerait par
imposer il y en a un ma connaissance qui
qui l'a fait c'est démissionner au au
niveau un des gros problèmes c'est la
rénovation de la représentation
politique si vous prenez la l'assemblée
je crois que c'est 55 % des
parlementaires sont issus de la fonction
publique nous n'avons absolument rien
contre la fonction publique nous avons
une fonction publique de très haut
niveau une administration de très haut
niveau mais aujourd'hui 55 % du
Parlement alors que le poids dans le PIB
c'est 20 % on commencerait par par
imposer la démission de la fonction
publique à chaque député pour pouvoir
renouveler renouveler le brun le maire
par exemple de l' c'est à lui que je
pensais c'est exemplaire il s'est
appliqué à lui-même appliqué à ça il est
pour enfin voilà voilà euh il y aurait
tout un volet alors en fait si vous
allez sur le site nouscitoyens.fr nous
avons
sélectionné 10 10 thèmes qui nous
paraissent essentiels la vie Politi la
vie politique la vie politique vous avez
l'exclusion contrairement à ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure Julie qui est un
des vice-présidents il a monté une
entreprise qui fait de l'insertion
sociale h est-ce que thbaau Julie n'est
pas plus qualifié qu'un certain nombre
de politiques hors sol qui sont des
politiques de carrière qui une fois
qu'ils sont élus n'ont qu'une idée en
tête se faire réélire qui vivent dans
des administrations qui sont déconnectés
de la vie publique qui n'ont jamais fait
de CV qui n'ont jamais fait d'entretien
d'embauche est-ce que nous chefs
d'entreprise avec nos différentes
sensibilité est-ce que des cadres
d'entreprises qui nous ont rejoint
est-ce que des avocats spécialisés ne
sont pas plus à même de réfléchir sur le
pavé du code du Code du travail que
d'autres on parle de choses que l'on
connaît et et encore c'est pas pour
donner des leçons aux autres mais on
pense que la la compétence n'est pas
limitée qu'à
2500 élus qui gère le pays ENF il y a
quand même aussi beaucoup de chefs
d'entreprise qui n'ont jamais présenté
le moindre CV à qui que ce soit parce
qu'ils sont arrivés dans l'entreprise en
sortant de leurs études donc c'est pas
non
plus tout d'un coup merveilleux le monde
de l'entreprise ou
on aurait que que des gens absolument
merveilleux ça c'est la première chose
ensuite c'est une très belle idée
d'exiger que les gens démissionnent mais
faudrait encore savoir ce que vont faire
les gens quand on se présente et qu'on
est élu député pour 5 ans qu'est-ce
qu'on fait au bout de 5
ans non mais qu'est-ce qu'on devient
c'est tout quand on a quand on a un
certain boulot on fait quoi on a pas de
boulot donc du coup on se représente pas
et on a un personnel politique pas non
s'il y a pas de possibilité s'il y a pas
d'avenir pour un homme politique au bout
de 5 ans on va c'est vrai c'est vrai qu'
un certain nombre de professions
libérales chef
d'entreprise ne se présente pas aux
élections parce que voilà il risquent de
perdre leur
boulotz
P
pas il y av une proposition qui é qui
est faite conjointement c'est d'imaginer
des des accompagnement pour les les
députés qui ne seraient pas réélus pour
les pour les accompagner mais ils on
n'importe quel franç la vie politique
c'est c'est un des facteurs
importantsz
approuvver les propos de pour
toi c'est vrai que on reproche souvent
la déconnexion de la réalité des hommes
politiques euh dans le meilleur des cas
ce sont des gens qui ont fait d'autres
études de la politique qui font lesat
mais très souvent ce sont des gens qui
rencontrent peu de difficultés d'ordre
social économique qui naviguent dans une
sphère plutôt haute de la société et qui
se retrouve forcément en décalage total
avec la
réalité peut-être pas des tr/ des
Français mais au moins des un bon de
tiers des Français je pense que
justement un chef d'entreprise alors
c'est vrai he comme Jean-Charles le
soulignit il y en a qui sont exactement
dans le même cas de figure mais un chef
d'entreprise qui peut non mais encore
une fois alors je vous laisse finir mais
il nous dit on n'est pas un mouvement de
chef d'entreprise peutêtre
pas je sais pas que j'étais là pour
justifier possibilité le droit des chefs
d'entreprise c'est pas des chefs
d'entreprise qui en voilà doncis dire ça
pour que le propos soit clair quoi oui
en tout cas leur candidature je la fous
parce que je pense que ce sont des des
gens qui ont certainement un éclairage
une lecture des des problèmes de la vie
quotidienne qui qui est certainement
plus àérré parce que lorsqu'on dirige
alors vous allez me dire pas le chef
d'entreprise mais si on prend l'exemple
du chef d'entreprise lorsqu'on dirige
une entreprise on est soumis à des
contraintes économiques que l'on doit
respecter et puis on doit faire sur le
plan humain aussi avec les contraintes
du personnel il faut le gérer ça au
quotidien donc je pense que on développe
nécessairement une forme de sensibilité
qui est tout autre que quelqu'un qui a
fait juste des études en politique et
qui souvent nourrit des une ambition
strictement personnelle là on est asse
dans l'air du temps Florence oui non
mais je pense aussi que par rapport à
votre programme puisque là vous avez
réfléchi en fait vous êtes parti d'une
feuille blanche sur la totalité des des
10 thématiques que vous avez sélectionné
et ce qui pourrait être intéressant
parce bon vous êtes un parti qui a 2 ans
d'âge il va falloir quelques années
avant de pouvoir grimper au sommet mais
je pense parce que le programme les
programmes que vous allez sortir et
j'espère qu'ils vont pouvoir être
médiatisés va peut-être aussi un peu
aiguillonner et allescouer les partis
politique traditionnel et les faire
réfléchir et peut-être aller sur un
débat et peut-être faire avancer des
choses au niveau des partis un peu
conservateur entre Guill tout alors
c'est vrai que il y a deux choses déjà
il y a un parti qui a très récemment
sorti une plateforme citoyenne donc nous
ce son c'est une somme de petite
victoire si on peut amener un certain
nombre de sujets sur la table on parle
beaucoup dans les ou ENF là là il y a un
parti enfin l'UMP alors c'est je sais
plus comment ça s'appelle mais le
citoyen Val ne parle que de
citoyen ce qui est important c'est je
pense que toutes les initiatives sont
sont bonnes à prendre à partir du moment
si on a un sujet sur le code du travail
qui est repris si on a un sujet sur la
la réforme de la vie politique qui est
repris tant mieux pas de prior dire qu'
voulait supprimer les par exemple donc
voilà mais ça c'est oui mais après on
est sur des on est sur comment app ça
des
marqueurs
on on est on est très loin de ça par
rapport à ce que disait
Sephora un chef d'entreprise ou un cadre
ou un artisan un commerçant quand il est
confronté à l'URSAF aux acidiques au
personnel j'ai des collaborateurs pour
lequel on reçoit des saisis arrêts sur
salaire donc on est quand même confronté
et vous pensez que les autres sont
tellement éloignés Stéphane justement on
est quand même un peu ENF je sais pas si
c'est vrai pas vrai peu importe enfin
vous donz nous le dire peut-être mais un
peu dans dans la mode quoi l'air du
temps de dire il y aurait vrai des gens
qui ne conna Trent rien aux difficultés
des Français parce que ils sont
fonctionnaires parce que aussi et et des
autres qui seraient confrontés aux vraie
réalité c'est aussi simple que ça c'est
c'est extrêmement compliqué en tout cas
mais mais
enfin c'est je c'est vrai que c'est
c'est pas si c'est pas à la mode enfin
c'est c'est c'est au contraire je crois
d'un grand classicisme ce ce type de
discours qui qui s'exprime de manièreon
foujadist à un moment et qu'on a oui
alors c'est pas c'est quand même pas du
poujadisme hein mais euh mais il y a il
y a il y a cette idée derrière aussi de
de enfin de de confusion entre ce que
c'est que la représentation et ce que ce
que c'est que la représentativité c'est
pas la même chose euh on court après la
représentativité aujourd'hui en disant B
euh il y a les fonctionnaires
représentants dans dans le dans le pays
et il devrai représenter pas plus ou au
moins pareil dans au Parlement par
exemple
euh alors la parité homme-femme
procéderit pas tout à fait de la même de
la même origine parce que oui mais enfin
c'est quand même le j'allais dire le le
le le la dualité incontournable
inévitable du genre humain mais aller
au-delà c'est une course sans fin euh
euh après on dira que Ben en effet les
artisans commerçants profession libérale
alors profession libérale non mais
artisans commerçants représentent très
peu sont très peu représentés euh mais
le problème n'est pas là euh euh je je
je ne pense pas que parce qu'on aurait
une espèce de Parlement qui
représenterait l'exacte photographie de
la société française les choses iraient
mieux ça j'en suis pas certain la
représentation c'est pas ça ça c'est la
représentativité et c'est une course euh
dans laquelle au cours de laquelle et
dans laquelle on se on s'épuise sans
jamais atteindre son but euh alors le
discours aussi sur c'est pas c'est pas
le discours que j'entends quand même
mais mais un peu il faut gérer déjà
gérer c'est un terme on dit plus
administré parce que ça c'est
fonctionnaire
on dit gérer il faut gérer mais encore
une fois ça n'est pas ce que vous bien
euh euh peu contrib à ça il faut gérer
une par exemple une une une collectivité
publique comment on gère une entreprise
et puis on on voit alors notamment au
niveau local des maires qui disent il y
en a un pas loin d'ici gérer une commune
c'est comme gérer une entreprise et Cera
et CEA mais non non non et heureusement
et heureusement qu'on ne gère pas une
entreprise comme on gère une commune et
heureusement qu'on ne gère pas une
commune comme on gère une entreprise
parce que la commune en effet ou et
heureusement pour nos communes euh parce
que les objectifs sont évidemment pas
les mêmes et au fond au bout du bout les
objectifs se rejoignne évidemment que
des entreprises soient en en en bonne
santé
économique qui cré de la
richesse mais mais c'est pas la même
chose et puis enfin il y a un dernier un
dernier une dernière thématique vous
vous aimez les fonctionnaires et j'en
suis j'en suis flatté moi je je je si
vous voulez moi je me sens plus je
fonctionnaire ENF la question m'importe
peu je je serais prêt à ce qu'on
supprime en tout cas pour les
universitaires le statut de la fonction
publique dès lors que on aurait
l'équivalent de ce qui se passe on les
cite toujours en exemple sans trop les
connaître aux États-Unis hein on a les
mes collègues ont des contrats de droits
privé mais qui sont des contrats un peu
solidifiés si vous voulez pour le leur
donner la sérénité sur le long terme ous
sont mieux payé que qu'ici non un peu
plus mais mais mais mais la question
n'est pas là finement bien sûr moins
souvent la
piscine ils en ont à l'université même
ce qui n'est pas notre cas je plein pas
mais mais si vous voulez là le le bah la
fonction publique c'est un coup je suis
d'accord euh mais c'est pas que ça euh
c'est aussi une richesse alors on a des
bons fonctionnaires on en a des mauvais
il y a des gens bien et pas bien partout
il y a des feignants du côté de la
fonction publique alors on dit mais il
reste je suis pas je suis pas si sûr que
cela et quand on veut dire quand on
propose je je crois que ça fait partie
en tout cas de ce que l' frrappe suggère
euh de baisser c'est le volume le nombre
des fonctionnaires alors en général tout
le monde est d'accord je prouve plutôt
mais alors après il faut dire
où c'est vrai qu'il y a des choses par
exemple dans l'actualité la présidente
de Lina par exemple qui est classé au
ministère de la Culture ça peut choquer
faut dire il faut est-ce que il y a trop
de médecins ou d'infirmière hospitalier
hospitalière est-ce que il y a trop de
profs dans les collèges et lycées alors
certains disent oui mais moi j'ai pas
envie que mes enfants soient dans des
classes à 45 j'ai envie qu non
mais je crois que les mêmes qui qui
réclament une baisse des effectifs
veulent plus de médecins plus de flic
plus de c'est le
syndrome on veut des routes des
aéroports mais pas dans le fond de son
jardin alors on va terminer on va passer
au près mais Jean-Luc je vous ai
interrompu tout à l'heure et pardon
parce que vous vouz vouliez dire que
voilà vous avez on reste là dans des
discours très très convenu ce qui
m'avait intéressé dans le mouvement nous
citoyens
dans ce que j'entends c'est ce que vous
nous dites il y a rien qui change or Dey
Perre et le mouvement nos citoyens
d'ailleurs le titre du mouvement dit
tout c'est que il avait compris que la
nécessité d'un homme capable de faire
bouger les choses c'était de remettre de
l'ordre dans la nature même de la
politique ça veut dire quoi le politique
est d'abord au service du citoyen point
numéro 1 donc le n'est pas le chef et ce
qui est terrible c'est qu'aujourd'hui
les combats que nous voyons dans les
partis politiques c'est pour devenir
chef stop ça nous intéresse pas nous de
savoir qui va être le chef ce qui nous
intéresse c'est que les hommes
politiques qui sont à notre service
entendent ce que nous leur disons et
bien entendu les discours les
propositions l'évolution de la société
ça va venir du haut vers l'homme
politique or là on entend et c'est ce
que je viens d'entendre à l'instant que
on va aller chercher vers le bas hein
c'est le grand principe de rafarin la
France d'en bas flute renversons la
pyramide en plus de la table table ça
veut dire quoi l'homme politique ou la
femme politique doit être au service du
citoy nous citoyens est une excellente
idée maintenant il faut la mettre en
œuvre en faisant quoi simplement en
remettant ce que moi j'appelle les corps
intermédière je sais que ça vaut s
quiquine un peu parce qu'on répète
toujours les mêmes mot mais en même
temps c'est quoi on parlait de la
représentativité elle est inexistante
dans ce pays à un moment donné il va
falloir quelque part que des gens se
préoccupent de remettre en haut le
citoyen et que le citoyen aille vers
l'homme politique qui doit l'aider à
participer à créer le mouvement
nécessaire pour aller vers l'avenir je
dis très souvent que moi le combat que
je mène quelle que soit sa nature va au
profit de mes enfants et de mes
petits-enfants je m'intéresse pas à
moi-même je m'intéresse à l'avenir et là
j'avais cru trouver dans Denis per
quelqu'un avec son mouvement qui était
dans ce mouvement d'avenir je l'ai perdu
à un moment donné mon cher Thomas pardon
j'espère que ça va être rectifié mais
au-delà de renverser la qui est une
image peut-être un peu brutale mais je
pense qu'il faut que la pyramide
s'inverse il faut que les citoyens
soient à la force de persuasion vers les
hommes politiques qui eux sont là pour
l'action citoyenne sont là pour écl de
décrire c'était plutôt simple enfin
c'est exactement ça c'est-à-dire que
N on souhaite passer d'un système
jacobin à un système inversé c'estàdire
que ça doit partir des citoyens la
charte citoyenne elle a été construite
comme ça et c'està-d le nom de parti est
un problème comme nous moi je suis Sy
our jeis
syee a peur de le mot syndicat sy
aujourd'hui aussi B que le
parti M nous nous parlons de
d'organisation
professionnelle bien la cosmétique
démaquill un autre mas pas le CH SPP
autr par Ju rent
je vous
propose plutôt que de parler mais venez
venez avec nous collez des affiches
venez avec nous sur les marchés vous
allez voir la réalité citoyenne non mais
venez venez avec nous vous allez voir la
réalité citoyenne franchement et donc
aujourd'hui notre notre ambition c'est
que un un moment un autre c'est de
pouvoir être suffisamment fort pour
pouvoir renverser la table et ça veut
dire quand même qu'il faut mobiliser un
maximum de citoyens et ceux de toutes
origines on vient on vient de d'assister
aux élections au sein du Parti
socialiste je dire je suis désolé les
les militants du Parti socialiste sont
pas des sous-citoyens des sous-hommes
ils ont voté en leur âme et conscience
pour pour des gens enfin je vois pas où
est le problème c'est sont bien des
citoyens qui sont allés décider qu'ils
allaient soutenir enfin dans tous les
partis politiques c'est comme ça les
citoyens ils se déplacent que ce soit le
citoyen du MP le citoyen socialiste ils
sont ils sont allés hier voter ils
ontb se mais non mais je veux dire arrê
arrê non mais arrêtons arrêtons de
toujours dire que tous les aut que tous
les autres partis politiques seraient
pas bien et ca les citoyens ser pas les
citoyens ils se prennent en charge ils
vont voter pour qui ils veulent ils ont
on est dans une démocratie il y a
suffisamment de partis et tant mieux
s'il y en a un nouveau je suis ravi et
bienvenu mais voilà c'est pas une
révolution le citoyen a tout le pouvoir
qu'il veut il est capable voter pour un
con c'est tout après il a le choix
mais le premier parti en France ce sont
les
abstentionnistes contradiction cela dit
entre une volonté comme ça des Français
qui serait en effet d'avoir une nouvelle
politique d'avoir de nouveaux partis
d'avoir de nouveaux représentants puis
quand on a des élections qui choisissent
au fond ils choisissent les plus les
expérimentés les plus anciens les les
peut-être les les plus forts d'ailleurs
dans dans la dans la façon de une
campagne politique mais est-ce qu'il y a
pas une contradiction entre les ces deux
souhaits comme ça de renouvellement et
au fond le renouvellement se fait jamais
il y a un problème de communication
aussi parce que sur la visibilité de nos
citoyens c'est pas simple aujourd'hui on
a une légitimité sur les sujets plutôt
économiques donc on a pas de problème à
avoir des articles dans les journauxou
dans les médias économiques la grande
difficulté c'est de casser le Plon vert
oui et quand je vois le débat et toute
la défiance que j'entends vous êtes chef
d'entreprise c'est suspicieux vous êtes
ceci vous êtes cela alors déjà on est en
train d'essayer de regarder où nous
mettre dans quel case dans quel case il
faut vous mettre même même le fait d'êre
bien sair
dro voudrait faire éclater ça
mais on nous reproche d'être un parti
vote pour vous on nous reproche non mais
c'est il aimerait les donné on lui donne
pas le micro sauf on aimerait reproch on
nous demande est-ce que vous êtes un
tingtang quoi on dit très simplement on
est un parti politique on nous le
reproche alors qu'on a' pas le choix
juridiquement nous sommes obligés d'être
un parti politique donc ça me mesure ça
mesure le chemin qui nous reste à
parcourir moi ça me motive encore plus
quand il y a des défis euh autant se
donner un maximum de moyens et ça veut
dire qu'on va devoir encore plus fédérer
et encore plus avancer et encore plus
convaincre tant mieux et on verra au
bout du bout ce qui ce qu' en ressort
mais je je crois énormément et je sens
tous les jours que le mouvement prend
que la maillonnaise prend et rien qu'à
voir en préparation des régionales le
nombre de partis traditionnels qui nous
Appell qui nous sollicite je me dis ça y
est on commence à rentrer dans le
spectre aujourd'hui Patrice vous nous
invitez c'est aussi et merci de nous
laisser le temps de de le faire
peut-être que j'ai pas encore les mots
c'est mon premier plateau télé donc il
faut aussi que nous on apprenne à
communiquer et et à et à avancer sur la
vie politique pardon parce que on fait
la vie politique aujourd'hui on peut pas
gagner seul donc il faut à un moment
faire des choix il faut aller d'un côté
ou de l'autre malheureusement c'est
comme ça enfin du côté de de la droite
ou du côté de la gauche on voit bien par
exemple le Front National qui est assez
puissant mais il n'y arrive pas tout
seul parce qu'il n'a pas d'alliés est-ce
que vous vous dites clairement bah voilà
si jamais on doit faire des choix on ira
dans tel sens ou dans tel sens c'est un
débat interne au au mouvement et qui est
justement comme on voit voit aujourd'hui
qu'on est de plus en plus sollicité euh
c'est un mouvement aujourd'hui qui n'est
pas tranché à 100 % mais qui est qui est
qui est qui est mené actuellement pour
savoir est-ce que ils doivent signer la
charte nous citoyens quels sont leurs
leurs approches quels sont les les
marqueurs ou les incontournables qui
font que ou qui feront que nous pourrons
aller nous associer ou avancer avec tel
ou tel mouvement ou parti ou tel ou tel
candidat très bien on on passe à
d'autres sujets si vous êtes
doit brûler les lèvres de beaucoup parce
que là non mais on est on est dans la
forme mais dans le fond tout à l'heure
vous parliez de pragmatisme concrètement
quel est votre objectif et quelles sont
les actions concrètes que vous menez sur
le terrain pour arriver à vos fins ce
que vous envisagez mais
concrètement concrètement c'est de de
pouvoir être présent partout au régional
parce que les régionales vont être un
trempelin pour les présidentiels c'est
de pouvoir on est en train de travaill
sur deux niveaux ce qui est de pouvoir
avoir des élus et dans un deuxième temps
et en même temps de pouvoir préparer une
nous sommes en train de préparer la
plateforme citoyenne sur lequelle nous
allons avoir un programme pour 2017 ce
programme il y aura deux possibilités
notre mouvement n'aura que 3 ans est-ce
que nous aurons un candidat ce n'est pas
sûr est-ce que nos idées seront reprises
est-ce qu'il y aura un candidat qui
ressortira qui dira je j'adopte le le le
le programme de nous citoyens et je
m'engage nous prendrons des garanties
pour ne pas être euh les dindon de la
farce comme en 2007 où Nicolas hullo a
fait signer à tout le monde et le lemain
donc ça ça voudra dire aussi qu'il
faudra qu'on a des représentant de nous
citoyens qui puissent aller agir donc
faire partie des des gens qui pourront
agir donc c'est soit dans un
gouvernement ou soit dans un dans un
mouvement si nous n'arrivons pas à ça
nous aurons des candidats nous sommes en
train de nous organiser pour avoir des
candidats en 2017 il faut pouvoir peser
est-ce que on souhaite en un candidat en
un candidat qu'est-ce que j'ai oui mais
après légis un candidat ça ça qui
jean-maravada non non Jean-Marc Cavada
quand il a rejoint le mouvement à la
demande de Denis perère nous av exp pour
vous avz prisan
conisavada enfin il a été il a été
bérouiste après il est passé à l'UDI
c'est pas le type même de du renouveau
en politique enfin il y a c'est un choix
que que Denis perère a fait à l'époque
pour il sentait aussi que le il ne
fallait pas que nous citoyens deviennent
moi Dey perère donc c'est d'appeler des
gens autour de lui pour l'aider à à à
structurer le mouvement et et le et
organiser donc Jean-Marie Cavada quand
il est arrivé avait il y avait un double
objectif derrière nous aider à
structurer le mouvement parce que N
passer d'un mode start-up politique à un
mouvement organisé donc depuis nous
avons créé le Comité des Régions le
comité exécutif qui fonctionne
parfaitement bien aujourd'hui nous avons
la charte citoyenne et nous allons d'ici
10 jours avoir un parlement citoyen nous
avons tiré au sort parmi les les
adhérents 200 adhérents qui
participeront au Parlement citoyen et
donc Jean-Marie Cavada est arrivé déjà
avec cette première fonction il nous a
expliqué en arrivant qu'il nétait
candidat à rien qu'il était là pour
donner de son temps et nous aider à
structurer le mouvement deuxième
objectif avec Jean-Marie Cavada pouvoir
enfin ouvrir les plateaux de télé très
simplement oui c'était c'était un accès
au médiia mais quel est votre programme
parce que là mais ça on en a parlé un
petit peu tout à l'heure ça vous brûler
les lèvres mais
nouscitoyen.fr voilà sur la pas écouté
c'est pas joli c'est donc le ressen
c'estensement de toutes les volontés des
citoyens pour essayer de les mener à
bien est-ce qu'on pourrait dire ça mais
non on est en train de travailler donc
sur un programme et ensuite avoir des
équipes sur le terrain pour aller le
porter euh puisque on par nouvellement
une question comme ça est-ce que vous il
y a deux personnalités qui qui alors
dans la politique plus classique he qui
sont dans dans le rouement il y a le
maire d'un côté il y aurait Vals
éventuellement de l'autre est-ce que
quelqu'un pense qu'il y a une chance sur
1000 que il soit candidat en 2017 l'un
et l'autre une sur 1000 sur 1000 oui
ouais sur 1000 oui mais pas beaucoup
plus
2017 oui ah ouioui parce y a quand même
c'est seé d' Busche pour Hollande quand
même donc c'est pas sûr du tout est en
train de
préparer pré mais je trouve ça vraiment
enfin curieux de dire qu'il y aurait
qu'une chance sur 1000 que Holland ne se
présente pas enfin ne soit pas comment
on dit en capacité pourquoi on est en
capacité plutôt que de pouvoir ou pas
pouvoir enfin bon donc il est il est
pour l'instant ils sont en capacité
d'êre d'être
candidat enfin en 2 ans il peut se
passer plein de choses ou
mais c'est vrai c'est vrai qu'on voit
même avec des gens qui sont plutôt
brillants que les Français aiment bien
c'est le renouvellement est quand même
difficile même surtout peut-être à
l'intérieur des partis quoi mais c'est
ce que je suis assez enfin je suis tout
à fait d'accord avec ce que Jean-Charles
disait moi je je on a les élus qu'on
mérite
voilà on vote et et chaque citoyen est
responsable de son vote le
renouvellement il incombe d'abord de la
respons il relève de la responsabilité
des citoyens eux-mêmes qui sont
électeurs alors c'est vrai qu'on peut
les y aider moi j'apprécie l'engagement
par exemple alors ce non ce fichu non
cumule des mandats enfin sans doute
va-t-on pouvoir y arriver mais encore ça
n'est pas sûr va falloir voir ce qui va
se passer justement en 2017 autour de
cette fichu élection présidentielle qui
cristalise qui qui qui qui enfin
stérilise tout débat qui monopolise la
vie politique française enfin tout
tourne autour de cela au bout de 2 ans
du mandatah ça y est on prépare prépare
ou surtout ave c'est absolument
insupportable moi
jecore tant mieux pour eu Patrice mais
vous le dites c'est une croyance ça
n'est rien de plus je vais fonder voilà
je vais fonder un parti je sais pas
comment ça s'appellera moi Stéphane
Manson et je et mon premier point ce
sera de supprimer la fonction
présidentielle ce que je dis aux
étudiants je je je vois j'ai vu dans ma
carrière jusqu'à 5 à 6000 étudiants j'ai
fait le compte et je leur dis
souvenez-vous je vais me présenter à
l'élection présidentielle ça durera un
mois et je ferai voter la suppression de
la fonction présidentielle voilà bravo
donc qu'on s'en souvienne monsieur vous
êtes vous seriez pour un éclatement
enfin vous êtes pour les institutions de
la 5e République ou vous êtes pour une
réforme par exemple de l'élection
présidentielle vous pensez que c'est une
bonne chose pour la démocratie ou pas
oui oui bien sûr vous êtes est-ce que le
nous nous on est pour que le président
en 2017
euh fasse un seul mandat il fasse le job
pour lequel il a été élu quel que soit
le programme mais au moins qu'on puisse
avoir ENF d'élection et vous avez un
bordel son nom parce que tout le monde
pense à la succession non il a 5 ans il
a 5 ans pour mettre en application ce
qu'il a présenté au français et que le
programme soit suffisamment clair au
moment des élections pour que ce soit
quasiment un référendum sur le
programme vous voyz comment si vous
voyez comment se termine les deuxièm
mandats généralement quand on sait que
le président ne se représentera plus
c'est pas très c'est c'est pas toujours
formidable voyez bien vous vous parliez
du cumul des mandats il faut bien qu'on
quand même changer la représentation au
niveau de l'Assemblée c'est veutd qu'il
faut faire voter ça par des cumularard
c'est compliqué quand même mais
l'élection présidentielle au souffrage
universel vous la remettez pas en cause
par exemple non non non d'accord non non
on n'est pas pour non non mais cétait
non parce que il y a des gens qui sont
pour la 6e République pour une autre une
autre façon une autre représentation en
politique peut-être un mot sur le on va
passer à d'autres sujets sur la sur la
sur le décret sur la réforme de
l'enseignement qui a été qui a été euh
adopté enfin qui a été écrit de manière
un peu précipitée disent les opposants
euh
vous avez beaucoup bossé Florence
là-dessus j'ai pas beaucoup bossé non
mais je veux juste rappeler quelque
chose on parle de précipitation de voilà
c'est un décret et un arrêté parce que
l'arrêté est beaucoup plus précis que le
décret le décret il fait trois lignes
euh l'arrêté est beaucoup plus développé
ils sont sortis en même temps alors on
parle de précipitation je le 19 au
mercred voilà le lendemain gr voilà
c'est ça le Lain de la grve donc c'était
mardi mercredi
euh c'est vrai que ça se ça se percute
avec les mouvements et qu'ils auraient
peut-être pu le faire à un autre timing
mais pour autant il faut quand même
rappeler que ce décret s'est arrêté
porte sur une loi du 8 juillet
euh 2013 donc on est bien dans le timing
typiquement français c'estàd qu'on est 2
ans pour sortir des décrets ou des
arrêtés voir même des fois on les sort
jamais donc dire précipitation alors que
c'est c'est plus un problème je pense de
de timing et de de de voilà ça se
percute avec avec les les manifestations
mais c'est pas voilà ça ils ont mis de
an pour
sation probblement par rapport à la
protestation exactement euh bon alors
après il y a le contenu hein on est
d'accord sur le contenu du décret de
l'arrêté j'entendais ce matin un
humoriste qui disait quelque chose de
bien il disait ENF en matière
d'éducation nationale c'est toujours
c'est comme le beaujolet ça revient tous
les ans c'est pas bon et ça saoule tout
le monde et c'est vrai que c'est un peu
ça quoi
oise c'est ça c'est bout de banane c'est
pas moi je trouve qu'il y a deux choses
dans ce qui vient de se passer euh la
première c'est que dans les débats on a
confondu réforme de l'éducation et
réforme des programmes première chose
réforme du collège et réforme de
absolument la deuxième chose c'est que
vous voyez bien que c'est un marqueur
politique aujourd'hui Hollande est en
train de rentrer en campagne très
clairement et son voyage au Caraïb est
significatif dans ce domaine et là
qu'est-ce qu'il dit Hollande il dit je
vous ai promis des réformes je fais des
réformes contre vents et Maré c'est un
marqueur politique très très fort qu'
est-ce que c'est un marqueur si fort que
ça parce l'opinion publique voit
quoi y a la mousse il y a la mousse
médiatique il y a les débats il y en
avait un brillant hier entre le maire et
valobkassem honnêtement la seule chose
qui importe pour François Hollande c'est
le marqueur politique qui consiste à
dire j'ai promis des réformes je réforme
voilà et ça ça va s'accélérer prment
dans les les mois qui viennent jusqu'à
2017 et vous allez voir
queim la seule chose qui lui importe
c'est de dire le changement je l'ai
promis je vais le faire contre V et Maré
et effectivement Florence a raison c'est
vrai que la loi elle date déjà d'un
moment et que là on est en train de
faire de la mousse sur un débat en
confondant en plus un certain nombre de
choses qui ne devrait pas être confondu
par les médias qui je trouve d'ailleurs
manque un peu de compétenence dans ces
domaines et pour moi la seule chose qui
compte c'est le marqueur politique d'un
président qui a promis des réformes qui
les fait contre V et Maré c'est de la
mousse mais en même temps il est en
campagne c'était pas son image c'est pas
l'image jusà pr pas l'image qu'on lui a
donné depuis quasiment depuis 3 ans
c'est l'image qu'il va défendre pour les
2 ans à venir euh là-dessus oui oui
enfin après peu importe que la loi dat
de 2013 ou pas ce qui est sûrement
choquant enfin au-delà du fond de de la
réforme du programme parce
que c'est ça qui est intéressant mais
sinon c'est vrai que c'est c'est assez
curieux le gouvernement qui a cette
habitude quand même il perd une élection
avant même de l'avoir perdu dis de toute
façon quel que soit l'ampleur de notre
défate on changera rien bon là les gens
descendent dans la rue les profs les
enseignants enfin les les syndicalistes
les élèves les parents d'élèves de toute
façon c'est pas gra on changera rien
donc effectivement c'est c'est une
question de méthode qui moi je trouve un
peu curieuse et voilà après ça c'est sur
la forme le c'est vrai oui c'est vrai je
trouve ça étrange eux qui en plus ont
toujours tendance à à prener l'écoute du
peuple et c'est vrai je trouve que pour
un gouvernement de gauche c'est d'autant
plus criticable parce le peuple on sait
pas on sait pas très bien en même temps
c'est plus temp il y avait rien à
écouter elle avait été voté il y a 2 ans
le décret sortelle été voté il y a de an
mais les gens il y a pas eu de
communication autour donc les gens n'en
avaient pas ça ça va rappeler parce que
même Valo balcassen quand elle parle de
cette problématique de cette réforme des
collèges elle rappelle pas personne n'a
rappelé que la loi était de 2013 sa
pas pas àép assez opposé au fond de fond
de la
réforme mais il faut c'est vrai qu'il y
a une confusion avec les programmes et
là il y a de la discussion avec les
profs s'en fout bon c'est collèges
pasuniversité l'université est réformée
tous les tous les 2 ans donc enfin bon
je j'y comprends encore moins d'ailleurs
de choses non non mais moi mon sentiment
c'est que c'est que tout cela marque le
le le
caractère enfin plus qu'important
capital de de de du service public de
l'éducation puisqueà chaque fois chaque
évidemment chaque gouvernement tente à
vouloir y laisser sa marque euh ça
suscite très souvent des vagues regardz
en effet sur la question des langues
dites mortes euh enfin c'est enfin c'est
très français ça imaginez ce ce la la
transposition de ce débat aux États-Unis
par exemple bon ENF ça leur paraîtrait
surréaliste d'ailleurs j'ai un ami enfin
je lui racontais il voilà il VI c'est
c'est safen je CIS c'est tellement
français comme commeud Françis comme
langue morte
notamment mais mais donc non non mais ça
en effet c'est ça ça marque vraiment le
alors c'est c'est plus que l'éducation
parce que c'est c'est c'est alors pardon
de d'utiliser cette expression mais
c'est au cœur de d' du du PACT
républicain enfin c'est fondateur quoi
le le le l'éducation l'éducation au sens
large euh donc là on touche à quelque
chose de très très délicat et on a
l'impression justement que les Français
sont très attaché à ça ou très très
attachés et à chaque fois qu'on essaie
d'y toucher on dit c'est délicat ou mais
il
il y a la réforme de du du du mammou
comme disait allègre et puis là c'est un
peu différent là c'est plutôt
l'attachement en effet je pense des
Français à leur système éducatif quoi
qui qui peut-être mis en cause par ou
pas par par la réforme ça c'est autre
chose peut-être un
mot toujours toujours Florence sur les
enfants d'un GP à l'étranger
euh là aussi bon le gouvernement avait
dit y aura pas de lien entre le mariage
pour tous et et les la
procréation soit la procréation a existé
soit soit la
GPA en fait c'est compliqué quoi le
statut des enfants surtout si quand on
va faire une GPA à l'étranger ils
reviennent en France qu'est-ce qu'il VI
non il y a un vrai problème d'intérêt de
l'enfant et je pense que la France a
déjà été condamnée à deux reprises par
la Cour européne des droits de l'homme
en juin 2014 et si le l'avocat général à
la Cour de cassation a pris une position
avant le 19 mai pour dire il faudrait
qu'on avance favorablement pour que ces
enfantsl puissent être inscrits à l'état
civil puisque c'est ça le sujet GP à
l'étranger le retour en France il y a
des
contentieux ils sont pas français ils
sont pas français ils sont il y a une
interdiction de les inscrire à l'état
civil donc il y a plusieurs il y a eu
plusieurs américain c'est ça voilà mais
ils veulent avoir la nationalité
française parce que les parents sont
français on des parents français il ont
des parents français absolument issu de
parents français et donc il y a eu
plusieurs contentieux à Nantes à Ren
avec des appels avec des décisions
divergentes avec des décisions disant
oui vous pouvez les inscrire à l'état
civil et puis des décisions o non vous
pouvez pas les inscrire à l'état civil
et et là voilà Jean-Claude Marin de
l'avocat général à la Cour de cassation
a dit il faut qu'on avance mais il a mis
une condition disant ils peuvent être
inscrit à l'état civil sous condition
qu'ils aient fait une expertise sur la
paternité pour prouver que le père est
bien père voilà donc on avancerait
là-dessus bon maintenant c'est juste son
avis je crois que l'affaire est étudié à
la fin vers le 29 mai dans la cour de
cassation et ensuite on aura la décision
euh soit euh juillet ou septembre sur ce
sujet là qui va être majeur mais la Cour
de cassation dit on peut pas ignorer les
condamnations en tout cas de la France
par la Cour européne des droits de
l'homme ça condamné deux fois et et
alors ça pose un un autre problème enfin
est-ce qu'il il y a pas une hypocrisie à
dire on est pour le mariage pour tous
mais ça ne va pas entraîner de
conséquences sur l'affiliation c'est
c'est exactement ce que ce que j'allais
dire sans sans ouvrir le débat sans
ouvrir le débat non est-ce qu'on est
pour estce qu'on est contre mais au
moment du Pax beaucoup d'opposants au
Pax avaient comme argument en disant
vous nous vendez le Pax et on sait très
bien que dans 5 ans ou 10 ans il y aura
le mariage et là tous les gens qui
défendaient le Pax mais jamais de la vie
mais mais vous rigolez non non le Pax on
s'arrête là et cetera 10 ans après le
Pax il y a le mariage les opposants au
mariage prennent le même argument en
disant ok on s'est fait avoir pour le
Pax on seit le mariage pour tous on veut
bien mais il va y avoir la GPA mais bien
sûr que non la GPA mais jamais jamais
vous inquiétez pas et là on attend même
pas 10 ans mais ça fait un an et demi et
claque la GPR c'est c'est pas la
légalisation de la GP sa bien dans les
tuyaux je ve dire une question de temps
je sais pas si c'est dans les tuau
demande pe les conteneux là sont des
couples htéros pas des couples
homosexuel non mais moi j'ai j'ai un
couple d'amis homo qui qui ont deux
enfants par GPA aux États-Unis ils
attendent qu'une chose et je leur
souhaite tout le bonheur possible c'est
que leurs enfants qui sont américains
puissent être français donc voilà
ça rien à voir entre parce que c'est
interdit là actuellement la GPA est
interdite en France mais pourquoi est-ce
qu'on interdirait l'inscription à l'état
civil d'enfants qui ont été conçus de
manière tout à fait légale à l'étranger
qu pourquoi interdire la GPA si on
reconnais au enfants nés par GPA
ailleurs le drit d'être français la
logique qu'on dit fait la GPA en France
pas lié ou pas lié on peut très bien
avoir une non enfin c'est assez
surréaliste quoi comme débart enfin je
sais pas alors on en fait quoi on les
met à la poubelle ah non
ça non je suis d'accord non non je suis
d'accord non non mais je dis est-ce
qu'on peut avoir le mariage pour tous
sans avoir s s s sans légiférer sur la
législation sans changer le droit de
l'affiliation oui oui moi je comprends
ça oui oui oui il y a quand même les
choses sont choses sont différentes bah
sont un peu nuancés quoi enfin la
réalité elle est souvent un peu plus
compliquée que le dogmatisme alors
notamment qui a prévalu sur ce ce
mariage pour tous ça nétait à faire que
Christi Christian tobira a été très très
clair sur le sujet pour une fois fois
pour une fois elle a dit ils sont
français point ouais absolument voilà
euh ben on arrive au terme de l'émission
euh juste un mot Thomas courtois sur ces
questions de société nous citoyens aussi
travaille aussi beaucoup travaille
commence à travailler euh on dans la
stratégie ou dans la démarche de nos
citoyens c'était déjà de de de
travailler de réfléchir sur la vie
politique et sur l'économie donc
remettre le pays en marche donc derrière
vous avez tous les thèmes dont j'ai
parlé qui sont sur sur le site
nouscitoyens.fr euh de l'éducation
l'écologie la vie politique euh ces
sujets de mariage pour tous ou de les
sujets de société sont dans un dans un
dans un thème qu'on appelle le faire
société donc derrière vous avez
qu'est-ce que la famille qu'est-ce
qu'être français donc tous les sujets d'
beaucoup parler en ce moment et notre
prétention c'est de pouvoir à un moment
un autre dire est-ce que ces sujets
peuvent être abordés différemment que
comme des chiffons rouges quand on prend
est-ce qu'on peut en parler qualement
Sarko c'était le l'identité là c'est le
mariage pour tous est-ce que des sujets
comme ça peuvent être abordés autrement
que comme des stratégies politiqu est-ce
qu'à la fin du fin ce que les citoyens
ne peuvent pas être appelés à voter et à
se
prononcer plus de démocratie directe
merci merci infiniment Thas courtois
merci Stéphane Monson merci Florence
mercad merci jeanluc MC
merci la et je vous garder pour la
fin merci à
tous
non CIT pas
fini